welcome to this week's edition of world
stories Nigeria millions threatened by
famine Greece living with a crisis but
first a layoffs where a new
hydroelectric dam on the Mekong River is
nearing completion it's a
much-anticipated source of hard currency
but thousands face resettlement and much
farming land will be lost forever a
picturesque boat journey along the
mekong river takes us to the largest
hydroelectric dam in laos these images
are rare because getting permission to
film is difficult that's hardly a
surprise the sayre buried am is one of
the most controversial building projects
Southeast Asia has ever seen it's due to
start operation in 2019 and will produce
1,200 megawatts of power the electricity
will be exported to Thailand and is
likely to pump billions back to Laos but
there are major concerns about the
environmental impact as a stone did you
loom the cyber Edom will affect the
entire ecosystem the water level fishing
stocks and the harvest of the algae in
the Mekong people living downstream
already noticing the effects more
studies on the environmental impact need
to be conducted nunca en una piccola the
Thai company behind the project says
it's taken those environmental concerns
into account it says that fish will be
able to pass through specially
constructed streams and that the plant
will be cleaned regularly to avoid
contamination
but that hasn't reassured many of the
locals some have already experienced the
negative impact Chinese damps have had
on the upper Mekong River fish stocks
are down and flooding has become more
common most people are too afraid to
voice their concerns on camera they fear
they'll face retribution from the
government the project has already
forced hundreds of families to move out
they'd been resettled in new
developments often far away from their
original homes though many of them do
say they're better off now we're gone
Holloman home it's better for us here
because we don't have to travel as far
to get to the rice fields and the new
highs are connected to the electricity
grid we also have better drinking water
laos wants to tap into its potential as
a major producer of hydroelectricity
plans to construct more dams are already
in the works that could be good for
business but fears are growing the
Mekong will lose some of its charm
next up Nigeria years of insurgency have
left large areas of the country's
northeast on the brink of famine and
large numbers of people fleeing the
terrorist organization Boko Haram are
stretching authorities to the limit
yakubu is only two years old his short
life has already experienced
unimaginable horrors his family's
village was overrun by Boko Haram
militants his mother only managed to
escape with him at the last second
yakubu is severely malnourished there
wasn't much to eat while his family was
on the run and now safe in maiduguri
they have no money Dickie today for the
last month I could see he wasn't doing
well I gave him traditional medicine but
it wasn't helping he kept getting weaker
and weaker at first he would eat the
paste I made for him from peanuts but
then he didn't want it anymore wanna do
can I be IDK a car it's a mini it was
almost too late by the time his mother
heard about doctors without borders she
couldn't afford a regular Hospital here
the treatment is free
and it's super crazy we are seeing about
100 250 pregnant women a day is a huge
challenge but we try to keep our team's
well motivated and you can imagine
you're seeing 100 250 malnourished
babies it's bound to like every way on
you in fact the number of patients keeps
rising nigeria's poverty-stricken North
suffers from chronic food shortages the
threat posed by Boko Haram makes it
impossible for many farmers to grow
their crops in total Doctors Without
Borders treats more than 1,500 patients
every day in their three clinics in
maiduguri an estimated one and a half
million refugees has more than doubled
the city's population the local
government is overwhelmed it focuses its
efforts on the official caps for
internally displaced persons well good
enough kids on Monday you want there are
also refugees who aren't being counted
because they're living with relatives so
they're not identified as refugees your
baby just saying that guy's ID that's
not their surviving from the help of
locals and their relatives as long as
they aren't registered they don't get
free access to state services like free
hospital care very much vicini muscle
engine that's why you're cool booze
Family haven't received any support from
the state yakubu is now being treated at
a special clinic his mother hopes he'll
regain health and that shall finally get
government support at least providing
enough food to eat
greece what's changed since the dark
days of the debt crisis not a lot it
seems unemployment figures are appalling
and much-heralded reforms have proven
unpopular many are resigned to a harsh
and bitter future the job prospect
seemed promising for Katerina Stella and
Alina when they began studying
architecture and Athens those times are
long gone now all three work badly paid
side jobs just to make ends meet of
course I would rather work as an
architect than in a falafel shop because
we all have studied and invested in it
but I have to make a living you don't
know yeah I'm efficient I would like to
earn my money with something that I like
but that is just not possible here right
now after the healing there one year
after Greece received its third
financial rescue the situation for the
three women has become the new normal
the country faces staggering
unemployment rate of fifty percent among
the young falling wages in a dramatic
rise of people living in extreme poverty
and the worst is not yet over to receive
the next a tranche of 2.8 billion euros
the Greek government must enact another
round of contentious employment and
pension reform span mid-september while
the crisis has taken its toll on every
part of the Greek society thousands of
small businesses are struggling only to
survive for ten years Alexis da kuma
analyst has been running his marketing
agency in the heart of Athens because
many of his clients have cut their
marketing budgets the outlook for his
company is turning ever more precarious
the uncertainty is the worst thing which
is hurting us every time is bail out
with you it drags on for months they set
new targets which are unrealistic which
they don't get
Patriots the situation so we never see
any light at the end of the tunnel if
you will Katerina Stella and dalena have
put their ambitions on hold after taking
part in the countrywide protests last
summer they also feel exhausted things
are changing all the time there's really
no stability for us whatsoever and it
affects everyone I feel like for us this
crisis is a constant battle between
staying motivated and just giving up all
of our hopes in Greece everyone agrees
that last summer's bailout was only
kicking the can down the road a year
after the crisis was declared over the
country is still in a downward spiral
our final report is from Germany last
year thousands of refugees arriving in
the city of Munich were welcomed with
open arms we asked around to see what
the mood is today Munich had never
before seen anything like it in just two
days seventeen thousand refugees arrived
at the city's main train station
hundreds of volunteers greeted them with
open arms the world song Munich is open
welcoming and generous daughters Lucas
was one of the volunteers a year later
she said one of munich's largest refugee
centers every week to help distribute
clothes shopping list for today you see
the pictures you see shoes the Jama
underwear socks trousers she is proud of
what happened in those stressful weeks a
year ago levander suits Wagner loiter
father to earth we had our 200 people at
the door and we just kept telling them
don't worry everyone will get something
and then we got to work they came with
nothing and left with a full set of
clothes we did it complete I'll start
again on this hamburger shaft about
12,000 refugees live in the city today
but most Munich residents have no
contact with them and some people are
afraid of them the city has seen an
increase in crime rates but the police
don't see that as anything unusual many
see thus when I say that the majority of
these refugees a young man aged between
16 and 30 and then look at Germans of
the same age group they also commit more
crimes than 60 to 70 year olds to amjad
on deserve a glass cup in italy or
criminal l's it's the copa de subsidiary
togas Lucas wants to help people manage
these concerns she's now working on an
initiative with other volunteers to
bring refugees and longtime residents
together so the city's oldest and newest
residents can live happily side by side
you
you